when we first defined our tables we
defined the relationship between them in
terms of constraints now we are going to
implement that relationship into our
query using a join this join will allow
us to query the weather table for values
from a specific location setting we'll
start by adding an SQLite query builder
class variable at the top of weather
provider will initialize the SQLite
query builder and the static constructor
for the class describing the join
between both tables note since both
tables have a column named underscore ID
we must explicitly use the table name in
order to disambiguate which underscore
ID we are talking about in the join then
we can define the query the query is to
find using the question mark replacement
syntax these question marks will be
replaced by the query parameters since
we allow people to specify the start
date in the URI we're also going to add
a second selection which includes
checking to see whether date text is
greater than or equal to our parameter
next we'll add a method to get the
weather by location entry using the same
query builder note that we fetch the
parameters from our URI and build a
string array so they can be substituted
into our query note that if the URI does
not contain a start date we actually use
a different selection finally we add the
function into the query routine of our
content provider